hello there everybody white out the cigar
that's mate milder to smoke milder invite
you to play ball by calling the play yes sir
it's the chance all of you armchair managers
and quarterbacks have sort of been waiting for
I think everybody likes at one time another
to fancy himself as a major league manager or
coach professional football team or a college
team whatever it may be in the world of sports
or in you like to match your knowledge of sports
in any case with the big leaguers in the major
games just as they were played well here's where
you really find out if you know you're a football
baseball basketball boxing and sports in general
because we're going to play back for you some
of the most exciting situations in sports and
ask you to call the play and you can win one or
more $100 united states savings bonds and a box
of 50y towels by calling the play right and our
white owl special of the week so brush up on your
sports will you and we're gonna have the big
one for you a little bit later on in the show
but right now let's get the ball rolling like to
sort of warm you up a little bit for our call to
play game I'm going to ask you now as you watch
very closely a little bit later to call the play
at Madison Square Garden the Philadelphia Warriors
and the New York Knicks late in the fourth quarter
the Knicks are leading 82 to 81 as they get
that ball near the basket and working around
Simmons takes a set shot it's
no good and the ball is knocked
out of bounds by dick McGuire
the Warriors take possession
Jack George brings it down court for the Warriors
the ball goes into the pivot back to George
who shoots it sounds ending the game say how
well do you know your basketball you'll find
out on this one I'm pretty sure while the ball
is in the air the referee blows his whistle but
the ball goes through the basket now then the
question confronting you as a referee is to those
two points count you know in most sports after
referee is called time the ball is automatically
out of play now this is a real sport stopper I
believe on the other hand it might be quite easy
for some of you but let's see if you can call the
play you've got eight seconds George shoots either
the basket is good the Warriors win 83 to 82
did you call the play well even though the whistle
sounded while the ball was still in the air the
two points are good yes sir they count you see
if the ball has already left the players hands
before the whistle is blown the game is not
over until the shot has been completed well
how about that one sir of an easy one for a
starter wasn't it but believe me you better
break out the old rulebook because from here on
in they're gonna get a lot tougher say friends
if you try to whiteout lately I hope you have man
this is really living mmm such a sweet smelling
smoke you know if I live to be a hundred I'll
never smoke a mild cigar and tell you that right
now this is mild as a smile and good tasting too
good tasting and full of flavor a real good cigar
all the way every pup you take how about trying
to white out only cost a dime you know that's
all just to dine now sometimes more Nahanni
whirling making cigar so good and discharge
you're dying for it but of course the answers
in volume you see white ourselves millions of
cigars week after week after week and by selling
so many it can sell for so little just a dime now
if white owl gives you such outstanding bandy
for just a dime then why in the world pay more
for your cigar why pay fifteen cents or two for
a quarter or for that matter why pay ten cents
for any other cigar when for a dime you can get
such wonderful smoking for the white owl smoke
milder save money for the white owl cigar you got
two wonderful shapes to choose from the famous
invincible and the stylish slim trim panatela
made milder to smoke milder and just a dime
well let's try for a change of pace
now and get back to America's favorite
pastime you're gonna be the manager of a
red hot situation at Ebbets Field where
the Philadelphia fields are battling
those bums right there in Flatbush
skin on the mound for the Brooklyn
Dodgers it's a 1-1 ballgame runners
on second and third as Erskine
pitches to Willie Jones ball one
-
Erskine in the hole
all three
ball four Messersmith in a corner but didn't
succeed and the bases are now loaded next
batter is Connie Ryan to hide pop-up Roy
Campanella calls for it and foul territory
one out now but the basin is still loading
one one ball game and Bill Nicholson's the
next hitter strike one the lanxin of the
bullpens tough situation Carl Erskine on
the spot bases loaded one out strike two he swings
and misses Erskine bearing down in this situation
strike three and the next batter
due up is Robin Roberts the pitcher
there's one of every big-league manager has
to face at some time or other let's see how
you do with it now remember the situation
7th inning of a tie ballgame one to one's
the score the bases are loaded with two out and
Robin Roberts great pitcher is coming up to bat
and Koosman pitching pretty good ballgame now
would you let him hit or would you send on a
pinch-hitter that's a toughy I think but you're
the manager for the Phills and I'm going to give
you just eight seconds to decide what you would
do in that situation with the bases loaded two
out in the seventh inning of a 1-1 ball game the
pitcher Robin Roberts comes up to bat for himself
well now normally the right play would be to
let robin roberts bat for himself you see with
the score tied one and one with two men out in
the seventh inning and with a guy like Robin
Roberts pitching he's an ace and doing pretty
well in this ballgame then you'd take a chance
with him coming to bat craps driving in the runs
to help his own cause now in just a few moments
fans will be giving you a chance to win one or
more of $100 United States savings bonds and a
box of 50 white owl cigars by actually calling
a play across the nation our white out sports
casters are standing by in each white owl city
and one of them may be telephoning you for our
play of the week now to be eligible for this call
friends here's all you have to do simply drop me a
postcard or nose to Mel Allen care the station
to which you're now watching just like the one
you see there on the screen that's all you have
to do just an odor postcard to me Mel Allen care
of your station now each week in your city will
be calling a new armchair quarterback or manager
to call the play and win our big savings bond
award and the box of white owl cigars but that's
not all friends by registering for call to play
you automatically become a member of our living
room league and that will entitle you to some
really wonderful privileges now that's something
I know that every sports fan in the country would
like to have and as a special bonus this week the
first 50 people to register for call the play
in your city will receive a white out 5 pack
with 5 truly mild white owl cigars I hope that
you'll get in on this fun you'll have a lot of
fun with call to play so drop me a card or note
tonight really do that thank you very much and
now for our white owl play of the week the game
is between the New York Giants and the Cleveland
Browns now watch this play closely because it's
one in which you can win one or more $100 united
states savings bonds in a box of 50 white owl
cigars so I hope you'll call the play right
in the third period at the Polo Grounds
Otto Graham hands off to chick jig ad
who gains three yards to the Cleveland 26
making it third down and one to go for the
Browns the Browns by the way lead 20 to
10 this time outer Graham pitches out to
Ken carpenter he goes for three yards
in the first down on the 29 yard line
Otto Graham one of the game's all-time
great passers fades back to his own 25
it's a long pass intended for a Renfro
but it falls incomplete on the Giants 25
gram hands off to G K T he's no gain and
giant lines rather ferocious third and
10 and gram back to pass once more it's
a screen pass attempt but knocked down
by the giant mine looked as if it's on
the boys won mixed up there a little bit
Horace Gilliam standing his own 15 punt formation
gets his kick away it's blocked by Jim Duncan then
picked up by Kennedy on the 30 runs rated
17 before he's pinned down by government
well how about that now in professional football
can a player on the defense run with a block kick
or is the ball dead at the spot in which he
recovers the block cut now you as a referee
have to decide that question and if you decided
correctly you've got a chance to win one or more
$100 united states savings bonds and the box
of 50 white owl cigars so stand by if you will
because in just a moment or so we're going to
switch to the white house sportscaster in your
city who may be calling you to call the play
friends I'd like to take timeout just for a
moment for my favorite cigar so folks I'm what
a lot of people refer to as a free man so that
means I've got no Christmas problems girlfriends
diamonds and all the men friends white owl cigars
now gals I can't show you the diamonds right here
they'll just have to come as a big surprise to
you Christmas Day but I do have the white owls
here here they are the National famous white
owl cigars now there's a gift worth a box of
diamonds to any man wonderfully mild white owls
all the pleasure and smoke and enjoyment a man
could wish for yes and a box of 50 white hours
you know cost not more than five dollars and a
box of 25 not more than 250 now there are two
shapes to choose from the famous invincible and
the stylish slim trim panatela you know more men
have enjoyed white owl cigars than any other
ever made in the United States so ladies and
gentlemen you can't go wrong when you give a box
of beautifully wrapped white house for Christmas
a great smoke every day a great gift Christmas
day are you ready to call the play if you are
you've got a chance to win one or more $100 united
states savings bonds and the box of 50 white owl
cigars now our white owl sportscaster is standing
by in your city ready to call tonight's contestant
the referee rules its first and
ten for the Giants on the 17 the
Giants offense takes over as their
defensive team goes off the field
did you call the play while the right answer is
that a defensive player can run with a block punt
and that's true whether it be professional or
college football of course there are differences
in the rules as far as college and the pro ranks
are concerned but in this particular instance
college or pro you can run with a block kick
now remember to get in on the fun simply send
me your name address telephone number is send
it to me Mel Allen care of the station you're
now watching every week in your city you see will
be selecting a new contestant to call our play of
the week so drop me a card or a note tonight
won't you do that for me thank you very much
well that's our game for tonight friends so I do
hope that you'll plan to be with us next week for
another session of call the play in the meantime
remember to pick up some white owl cigars man
you'll really like them you've got two wonderful
shapes to choose from the famous invincible and
the slim trim stylish panatela and you can get
both shapes you know in the Handy white owl 5 pack